so there's this common myth that goes
around the internet that when you are in
your 20s you should be spending that
time trying to get ahead and as someone
in the 20s where most of my friends are
in our 20s i often like hear a bunch of
and and feel a bunch of existential
career risk angst around oh whatever
like i haven't really figured out what
to do with my life i haven't figured out
what my career path is going to be for
the next 50 years uh maybe i'm kind of
doing things wrong because i'm exploring
this youtube thing rather than doing
medicine anyway what you're about to
hear is a little snippet from a
conversation that i had on the deep dive
podcast with hannah witton where we talk
about this idea of getting ahead in your
20s and i think hannah gives some
amazing advice that every 20 year old
needs to hear were you concerned at all
about the youtube thing not being a
quote real job and what what is your
career going to look like 10 years down
the line you're still gonna be making
videos like all of those fears that
people have as they switch from a quote
proper job to a quote like not proper
job
i don't know because i never i don't
really ever feel like i had a proper job
yeah because
um even what i was doing for that
charity like i was a freelancer and i
was making youtube videos but just for
somebody else which if anything was
proof very early days for me that like
this is a skill that other people also
want like and will pay you for
but i think i have more of those fears
about like the longevity of it now than
i did then
like at the beginning i was just like
i'm riding this wave like this is going
well let's not like freak out let's just
keep going like build on this momentum
but also it was just me then whereas now
it's like
i rent a studio space i have a team
there's definitely a lot more of like
the business
element to it
now as well and maybe you can relate to
to this as well at the beginning i was
like in my early 20s had no dependence
had savings so i was just kind of like
your early 20s is when you move to
london and you take risks that's what
you're supposed to do right
um so it didn't
i didn't feel any fear there because i
was just like if this all goes tits up
like that's normal i'm 23. like
who cares
whereas now it's like oh i'm about to
turn 30 i'm about to have a baby i have
a mortgage i have a team i have a
business that has a lot of overhead
costs a lot more fears about the
longevity now than then for sure yeah so
on the point about your 20s being for
experimentation that itself is kind of a
novel thing i guess
for
medicine in particular your 20s are for
setting yourself up for success
in banking and consulting and law your
20s are like hey let's hustle hustle
hustle so that's when i'm 30 i'll have
my partner at mckinsey or whatever
people do
and a friend of mine um who's also was
also medic in my year who recently quit
medicine to pursue a job in tech put out
a tweet that went viral the other day
which is basically like you know
when i left medicine at 26 i was really
scared because for the last 10 years i
had a very clear path and now it all
feels like all this uncertainty but then
i realized actually my 20s are for
experimentation that tweet went viral
and people like was it i think
the the idea that you can actually just
like screw around doing stuff in your
20s and it's actually okay yeah yeah
it's actually fairly novel to a lot of
people well we put a lot of pressure on
on people to make a decision about the
next 10 years of their life really early
like and you'll know this like from
doing medicine at uni so like at some
point you decide you want to become a
doctor okay you have to do medicine at
university okay in order to get into you
need to do medicine i need these a
levels in order to get into college to
do those a levels i need these gcses at
what age are you making decisions about
what gcses you're doing you're 14. yeah
you're 14 and you made like all of those
decisions for the next 10 years of your
life like we specialize real early in
the uk um in terms of like those
decisions that we're making about our
studies and our work and career and
stuff i didn't have that because i went
the
humanities
route
but
yeah i do think that there is a lot of
pressure to like know what you want to
do and then also like as a
culture we idealize and like look up to
people who are really successful very
young we're like oh my god look at what
they've achieved and they're only 21.
like isn't that incredible but then you
find yourself actually comparing
yourself to a lot of these people who
had great success in whatever it is
they're doing super young yeah there's a
bunch of um examples in tech in
particular that they get thrown around
that yes there are some you know
19 year olds find founding stripe or
facebook or whatever but actually the
guy who founded linkedin was in his 40s
jeff bezos was in his 30s when he
started amazon like there are people in
their 50s starting these companies as
well yeah and like it's it's not a race
this is one thing that i find a lot of
people doing in our youtube academy
where
especially if it's older people
comparing themselves to the younger kids
and it's like if you're you know if
you're in your 40s and you've got a
family and a mortgage and a job there's
just no way you can give the amount of
time to youtube as like a 19 year old at
uni studying psychology who has one
lecture a week he's just like banging
out the content if you're over 60 and
you're retired maybe you've got loads of
time to dedicate to youtube like amazing
um
chelsea fagin who's the um ceo and
co-founder of the financial diet she
like often talks about how i think on
her instagram or like on social media in
general she basically only follows
influencers who are over 50. oh
because she's just like we're a youth
obsessed culture and
for her like she's in her early 30s and
she just wants to see older women
thriving because we also as a culture
kind of like you know you're a woman and
gets to a certain age and suddenly you
become completely invisible to the world
and so for her she like is actively
seeking out these like positive examples
of older women yeah just like thriving
and like doing their thing and i'm like
i love that that was brilliant hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day